it's robert kiyosaki hopefully we can
get them on the other day took us an
hour nearly to get my dad on we got the
man the myth the legend Robert Robert
how you doing once hello and you see me
can you hear me yeah we can hear you we
just need to turn the volume up give me
one second here good nice by the way
just just so you know I have my
eight-year-old son who's doing homework
with me right now sitting right next to
me kiddies Robert can you say hi you
don't want to say these a capita stunk
but today's gonna do a lot of talking
you might just go further up give me one
second here dawn right now we can hear
you yeah all right say something can you
see me can you hear me yeah I can hear
you now okay Robert how you feeling how
you doing I'm doing fantastic
I made this fantastic I'm worried about
the world but I'm doing good so I got to
tell you you know you're the first
person that's gonna know this you know
who I just had on by a table for the
last two and a half hours who David Icke
are you in trouble yet not yet I I spoke
to the attorneys and my approach I took
what the interview is a very very
different kind of an interview and it
was a very different kind of an
interview but we'll see what's gonna
happen it was heated from the beginning
to Deanna was heated so we'll see how
this interview does whether the powers
of YouTube are gonna let this thing stay
up or not I was wondering about that you
know because like you and I both went to
war and I didn't fight for this this is
communism you know I mean how in the
world can they take away the First
Amendment which is the freedom of speech
and the right to assemble that's all the
First Amendment and so they have social
distancing and they take down London
rail and Bryant you know puts his name
Alex Jones I'm not for or against them
but is the principle of the thing and
where we're losing our constitutional
rights that's what I and then I can
attack I can attack for talking anything
about that what's happened to our
constitutional rights and I get called
you know a tin hat or a tinfoil hat or
whatever it is and you know it's it's a
frightening time right now
it's a fright so I have a question for
you I have a question for very soon Oh
what you think about this is say Robert
Kiyosaki is the chairman of the board of
YouTube okay
let's you say Robert Kiyosaki is the
chairman of the board of YouTube you own
51% of YouTube okay and meaning you
control all the decisions and mainstream
media cannot stand you because you're
allowing anybody to create content and
you know they're calling themselves
journalists and didn't go to the right
school to call themselves journalists so
ABC CBS CNN a lot of these guys cannot
stand the content creators on YouTube at
what point as a chairman of the board of
YouTube would you decide for between
what kind of content you will add on and
what you want because a lot of times
when these types of platforms are
created some people say we can let
everything on well then maybe you're a
porn site and then if you leave anything
on well maybe some criminals can get on
and so how would you this is a very
sensitive topic and I'm curious to know
how you would answer this how would you
filter out content that can't stay on in
content that cannot stay on that's not
an easy question but the reason I'm
saying what I'm saying it's the First
Amendment you know with crushed so ok so
let's say that they take off London real
Brian Rose is a great guy he's an
educator know Kourt and I are educators
so they've got to consider at least who
the presenter is and what's their motive
they take off Alex Jones and a parent
that they take him off because he
supported Trump or something like I
don't know I all these rumors
and then zero heads or something they're
taken off so anybody who violates what
they call the elite or Silicon Valley
we're in trouble and so I'm I'm hesitant
to say anything today that's the worst
part about it
and my friend you know when you're on my
program I was talking about your book
wartime leader and peacetime leader
today if you're a wartime leader they
kill you
and and that's what's frightening about
this whole thing dick you know like I go
to my friend's restaurant he's out of
business and that's called social
distancing is called the right to
assemble you know I went to a party the
other night and it was we felt like
we're back in prohibition time you know
like we're just friends getting together
and my doctors are there and all that
you know they're going boy if everybody
found out about this they come and lock
us up well just like that guy in Malibu
who was what paddle surfing and they
told him in Jed I mean it's there was
something so sinister about this whole
thing and then you know when I was on
Twitter which I just my doctor gave me
the stats on coronavirus I got attacked
I got attacked and said stay in your
lane don't you dare touch that then I
talked to another friend who was a
doctor and he said he got taken down off
of YouTube and Twitter and all the
things I which I don't know much about
so my concern is we're messing with a
power that has authority over the
constitutional United States remember
that that the just that Supreme Court
justice what was his name Kavanagh or
something he gets accused and he's
guilty until proven innocent what is
happening and that's my concern it's how
can somebody and you know like even my
friend Jim Rickards you know of currency
wars and all that he treads lightly on
it he calls on the
he doesn't name them and the guys that
named them get taken down that's my
concern so I'm gonna be you know I'm
gonna mind my P's and Q's because as the
guy said to me
vaccines Bill Gates Robert Kennedy jr.
that's not your territory but I do know
a lot about vaccines and it's big
business let's just say that Robert do
you do you did you vaccinate your kids
or you you take vaccines yourself like
flu shots do you take any of that or no
no now they don't have children and I
don't know you know I really don't know
because it's not been mice it really
hasn't been in my mind I said I went you
the same called the red pill Expo
pinball's maan Montana put on by G
Edward Griffin the guy wrote the
creature from Jekyll Island
that is one of the most powerful classic
books written and and so I go to this
event and the press calls us white
supremists
that's what they said this is red pills
bunch of white supremacy and I said God
when did I turn white that's what I said
they didn't think it was too funny but
they never they never even showed up
they already branded us as white
supremists but it was the first time
this is about four or five years ago I
saw these nurses running around and the
little nurses outfits you know so I
asked them so what the heck you guys
doing here this is supposed to be you
know the red pill is about the matrix
you know you see the truth'll you see
the blue pill EP you see the [ __ ] so
these nurses are running around so why
are you guys here and they said what
we're protesting is the insurance
companies you medical the health
insurance and Big Pharma they require us
to inject drugs into people who don't
need it to keep the price high and it
said we do we are when we refuse to
inject whatever they inject I don't know
I didn't yeah I'm not a doctor they said
we can't do it in good conscience were
killing people or we're just jacking up
the bill
and only until I went into the emergency
room for one stitch when I got the bill
for $34,000 did I get the message and
then I went to another red pill this
time it was in Connecticut and there was
a doctor who stood up there he explained
the business of vaccines and then again
I'm not I'm not that's not it what but
what I'm threatened on all the time on
Twitter and the David Icke and those
guys the the business model of vaccine
is they cannot be sued if the vaccine
killed somebody so that takes away the
whole impetus of responsibility and then
they said there's so many vaccines now
that they don't really have to track
them but the biggest thing is this if
they can get it mandated that the
vaccine be mandatory and I and then the
business model works joining me could
you imagine the government said
everybody had to watch Patrick that
David and buy his products that's really
what it's about
so apparently I on my Twitter Hydra I
drifted into pharma big pharma and I
talked to my friend was a doctor who was
taken down because he was saying the
same thing he says he just stepped on
Superman's cape don't go there it's too
big a business anyway this you know
there's powers to be a Patrick that you
and I are just small little potatoes in
and guys like David I are the lightning
rods and you know I watched I watched
what I watch what David Icke said and it
was it's out there but I don't think is
that bad personally so I don't why take
him down might take London real time why
take Brian wheel down why take you down
why take me down so I
that's not concerned about and once now
I send a message to Brian Brian and I
communicated I think two days ago and I
told them I said you know this is this
is this has got nothing to do with
YouTube this isn't a YouTube thing did
you watch the interview done with the
CEO of YouTube with ABC did you
watched at 60 minutes no I think once
we're done here Robert remind me to text
you the link I think you and Kim have to
watch that interview okay you will see
the level of discomfort with ABC with
content creators with what YouTube is
doing it you know ABC is saying why are
you letting anybody create content
they're becoming journalists he says no
we don't consider ourselves that we
consider ourselves a social media
platform so mainstream media is not
happy about people like Brian Rose who
are sometimes getting more views than
what they're getting and that's not very
comforting but you know the part that
gives me more comfort Robert today than
before is the following like my biggest
challenge with China is I think a lot of
the issues with China would be solved if
they allow Facebook YouTube Twitter in
China where we could see what's going on
and you know 18 year old will be posting
videos and saying look look what's going
on over here look what's going on over
there look what's going on over here we
would we would know the reality of
what's going on in China for example I
had the former the shocked Iran son and
I had a meeting together in Washington
DC there's a good for our meeting we had
together I was there I kind of watched
Mike Lee and Ted Cruz do some stuff and
then I went and spent some time with him
we sat at the back of an Italian
restaurant phenomenal food and he was
telling me with this campaign the team
that he had what's going on in Iran
I said what's really going on anyone he
says I really think your honor is ready
for a revolution I said why do you why
are you so confident because I was right
he said the reason why there's
confidence for that to take place is
because women in Iran blog more than any
other country in the world based on per
capita meaning based on the population
that they have their blogging that's
just so what is that doing he said the
world is seen it from their point of
view of what Iran is really like and a
lot of the folks around the world either
say listen Human Rights that's just not
fair what you're doing
eventually there's gonna come so much
pressure that they're gonna be forced to
change because power to the people
We the People you know the whole nine I
don't think social media serves two
powerful people in the world I think if
there's any community that hates social
media as the powerful people they can't
stand it you know that so my my hope is
that enough with these folks are gonna
keep talking and you know some of the
stuff David says can be a little bit
sensationalized and some of this stuff
alex jones said was about the pizza gate
that was the thing that got him in
trouble by the way it wasn't Trump he
was said some stuff about pizza gate
that got him in trouble and that's why
they took it down but my comfort comes
in knowing that enough people are
getting access to information to start
questioning things and educating
themselves it's gonna be very hard to go
up against the community like that what
do you think about that I agree and just
to let you know I think you and I are
walking the line and I think that's one
of you know that's why your your piece
on wartime leader and peacetime leader
is I think we better become peacetime
pretty quick because we're gonna get
crushed because I'd rather fight you
know I create social distancing is 250
yards I can enter 250 apartments that
got taken down to you know not ordinary
times and I think I could explain why I
do what I do but I'm gonna be walking
the line if you know what I mean because
exactly as my doctor said because he got
taken down he says you stepped on
Superman's cape and that Superman's cape
and that's that's the battle between
Robert Kennedy jr. and Bill Gates and
those are two rich kids Annie and I not
rich kids so we'd better walk the line
you know I mean sometimes is sometimes
it's better to back off like we talked
about so that's where I'm at but I'll
walk the line on this next thing as to
why I'm involved why you're involved and
what we're saying but it's uncut it's
unconstitutional
how can you shut
their friends restaurant he's broke you
know I talked to my personal trainer and
you know he says to me his wife just
lost her job so he's broke too now they
both lost their jobs cuz he can't train
that's more damaging than anything I
know to affect a person's psyche their
emotions you know and stuff like that so
I think we're we're playing with
dangerous people and they look like you
and me Jen I mean so it's best not the
same thing because you don't know who
we're talking to anyway is it okay if I
talk about what I know is it is it okay
if you talk about it yeah no okay I'll
tell you why I'm in why I'm walking the
line and what I think is really going on
okay
no this is he got curious to know what's
on your mind so go forward okay so it's
why I started Rich Dad Poor Dad because
that's why I crossed over the line when
I was talking about vaccines being big
business it's killed more people than
this you know my I've had vaccines but
my mother was a registered nurse and she
put in vaccinate us it's not Tony to
something they know and I think the
problem is people look to you and me for
the coverage to say what they don't say
and that's why we have to be careful I
mean I was I was on a trip with Steve
Burke who's a CEO of NBC Universal and
he says he says you guys are killing us
yeah that's true we're killing big media
we're we're saying things that you know
and big media is controlled by the
government as you know that they can't
say anything
so when guys like you and I pop up in
Brian Rose pop up or Alex Jones pop up
and all the guys that pop up then it's
like whack-a-mole you know how do they I
don't think are they contain us I think
it's really the problem so they violate
the First Amendment the freedom of
speech you know political correctness I
can't say anything other thing that's
that's disgusting is that we we now we
we elevate we acknowledge the victims
and step on the heroes I mean that's so
it's very spooky times how does this
cycle get stopped because the cycle you
know if the cycle goes the way it does
where you create a system where like for
instance our the way we have our system
a president can only be a two-term
president right outside of FDR who was a
three or four term president well George
Washington didn't want to do that
because he says I'm not a king I'm a
president somebody else can do my job
and they can replace right how do you
how do you prevent that from happening
where the powerful people you know they
they pass the torch to the next person
because I think the system that we have
here somebody else comes in and takes
over is it that concerning to you where
you worry somebody at your phase of your
life you're worried about this long term
or you foresee a solution where
eventually they can't go the way they're
going right now because someone's gonna
put a stop to this
the Patrick let me just say it this way
you and I have got to become peacetime
leaders your job is too important
there's too many people that look to you
for leadership right now you get taken
out and they will take you out
it was the leader just just remember
that who all the people that look up to
you for guidance and moral support and
vision and all that that's your job
but I'm just giving you back what you
gave to me that become a peacetime liver
pretty quick because you go into war on
this one there's people much bigger than
us will kill us so that's so that's what
I'll tell you what I know and I'll stay
in my lane as I've been threatened
constantly so this is it here this is
how I see they all come make sure this I
can I can see this because it's called
the Dow Jones and
stroll average okay and what you see
here is 1929 that crash was nothing but
they brought in Social Security they
took away a gold 1933 so it goes along
so in 1971 Nixon takes a gold dollar off
the gold standard so that's why I wrote
this book here it's called fake okay
it's fake money
fake teachers and fake assets because in
1972 in January of 1972 I arrived in
Vietnam Nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard in 71 August 15 I didn't
know anything about it because Nixon
announced it on the TV show bonanza so
I'm now flying off a carrier in Vietnam
as a Marine pilot and I get this letter
from my rich dad he says hey watch out
it just took the dollar off the gold
standard it's my rich death my poor dad
in academic there schoolteachers are
clueless
you know I'm either think they're in
Disneyland
so my rich dad says hey watch out so
here and in fake I reckon sake money
fake teachers make it at big assets and
I said what the hell is gold because in
1933 they made it illegal for Americans
to own gold I thought that was really
strange
so my co-pilot and I fly behind enemy
lines and we're looking for gold Marines
aren't the brightest guys on earth then
when we get there we're now you know I'm
about ten miles behind enemy lines
negotiating with a Vietnamese woman to
buy gold and we realize we don't even
know what gold is that's how clueless we
are see when they take gold out of money
they can print as much as they like and
so that's why I write a buck and fake
its fake money and that's where this
whole problem starts it goes it relate
it relates to London rail to David I
because it's the same thing so it checks
along here and I'm going and and things
are fine what I'm now searching for
answers
so in 83 I read this book by Buckminster
Fuller consider when the greatest
geniuses of our times invented the
geodesic dome and he talks about this
the Grunch of giants and I thought that
was strange
so this 83-71 283 garage test for gross
Universal cash heist
I read that books not a very good book
small book but I understood it and
that's what that's what the conspiracy
guys come in it's all your your tin yet
or whatever they call you your
conspiracy guy I'm going well maybe
there is and it goes to the Fed so then
you have guys like Ron Paul and all this
attacking the Fed the Fed in my opinion
is a criminal organization because its
mandate is a lie it's not here to
protect you and I the Fed protects the
rich nothing wrong with it I understand
you got to have your association iam a
protects doctors and the Fed protects
the rich I understand I just chose to be
on the side of the rich like what they
do so I read in 83 Grunch of giants and
suddenly I can see this happening so
this is the towel that goes up that's
2,000 that was a dot-com crash 2008
subprime crash this is 2020 and the
question is how far is this crash gonna
go and this is my point here I think the
coronavirus is to cover up this and I'm
probably good if I'm dead tomorrow
you'll know wise because I was on your
program so let me show you what happened
here so this is what I did so I
documented exactly as Fuller said to
document what you do so here is 83 I
read crunch of giants this is the cash
flow key so in 80 the main ninety six up
came off 96 I created the cash flow born
thing okay and that was my wife and we
did that because what fuller called an
artifact so they could kill me but my
artifact is
now all over the world we're playing
with some dangerous people
crunch growth Universal cash noise so I
created the cash flow board game with
Kim in 96 then I wrote this book here at
rich dad poor debt to explain the cash
flow board game because as you know
there's no financial education there are
schools so then I can attack by the
elites will run the university systems I
say why don't you guys teach us about
money because you're just as criminal as
they dead oh you don't know what you're
talking about so that's my quartet so
the world is run by bureaucrats who are
like my poor jet very smart people but
they know jack about money I think was
the Fed nine hundred PhDs and the fifth
and they can't haven't got it right yet
why cuz they work for the rich guys to
the fence a cartel the Fed is not us you
know I mean it's not owned by America
that's a cartel of very rich guys like
the Rothschilds that's the problem
you mess with those guys so then he goes
up so in 1997 so 1996 I create the cash
flow board game artifacts so Patrick if
they take me out this stuff's already
here so I'm right Rich Dad Poor Dad and
then this one here is Oh prophecy so I
write this book I started in 1999 and I
said the biggest stock marketing crash
in history would come in 2016 so I was
recording it because I understand the
game of money so here's two thousand and
I wrote in there because I'm a surfer
and every surfer knows wait
is this big wave sir it's not short
break short break are just sweat built
but a big wave surfer which I dreamed of
becoming at one time knows that ocean
swells come in sets of three go hop down
and they crash in threes so every surfer
knows that I mean that's I didn't do
well in school but did once
good idea so on schedule came the first
crash 2000 dot-com
there was also y2k for a member I didn't
understand that one either so then here
it goes back up again and 2008 so that's
the second way so one two three waves so
I'm a surfer I'm like oh there it is
they're printing more money we're going
back to here they can print as much as
they'd like to keep the Fed keeps
printing the money to bail out the rich
that's what creature from Jekyll Island
says the name of the game this is the
rich get bailed out you and I get
screwed so they privatize the winnings
you know the rich and they socialized
losses so when they bail it out that
means you and me the peasants of the
earth we pay for it
but the rich get bailed out so here I am
I'm on CNN so you guys can go to rich
dead calm you'll find me on CNN proving
I mean I everything I do is I prove what
I know
Zomba I'm on CNN with Wolf Blitzer and I
said in January I believe it was I said
hey Lehman Brothers is going to go down
and Wolf goes I was never invited back
but I got it in doing I mean I got it
did and so well yeah so go to rich
ted.com watch me on Wolf Blitzer calling
the crash of Lehman Brothers but it
wasn't the crash of wings buzz it was to
cover up the crash that was coming
so that sucker comes out so Lehman
Brothers a pink went down in September
of 2008 so I get guys six months warning
that this crash was going to come again
I'm a dumbass surfer what I do know the
feeling of waves you know when you're
surfing out there as a kid is a sixth
sense because it's is spiritual you can
feel it you can feel it oh it's coming
it's coming it's coming in like this so
it goes down here
hits there and that's so I said it's
gonna come in 2016 so that was prophecy
again I wrote a prophecy this came out
in 2002 so they hit a document created
an artifact as public luck mr. holder
said and it goes I said it was gonna
come in 2016 but what I did not foresee
I didn't say I didn't see the cell phone
in 2007 I didn't know what quantity
quantitative easing did not exist at
that time nor desert zero interest rate
policy I went holy mackerel so they were
tryna so it should have come at 2016 but
because of quantitative easing ZIRP plus
bitcoin came out in 2009 plus cellphone
is 2007 all this changes was happened so
it held it up so when so I could call by
The Wall Street Journal tore me apart
for prophecy they just tore me they said
we had a big deal where is it I said
it's still coming so then in September
2019 the repo market the shadow banking
system hemorrhages you know it
hemorrhaged and so it's so they fed goes
into a trillion dollar bailout trying to
stop the shadow banking system from
going meanwhile the stock market keeps
going up and mom-and-pop have no idea
what the shadow banking system is that's
where the Fed comes in so that thing
kept going up and I said something's
going to happen and what laughs so 2019
shadow banking market crashes so I knew
something was coming I didn't know what
it would be but something was going to
come cuz the Fed had to print trillions
and the Treasury 2020 on schedule
coronavirus on schedule so I was four
years off just because I didn't see
quantitative easing exist in 1999 or
zerp you know who would think money
would go to desert
interest rate policy so 2020 it goes
down the question is how far will it go
I never thought they were shut down the
whole frickin world economy I never
thought they would damage people like
you and me I never thought that my
friends who are doctors are going broke
gonna shut down their centers never you
know commercial real estate is going
bust and you know the guys who own
retail shops and all this they're just
turning in their keys you know I mean it
these guys grudge groves Universal cash
eyes looking up Buckminster Fuller and
this is where I get nailed and that's
what happens with David Icke because
he's talking about these guys will
control the Fed and the Treasury and
politics its global it's not an
individual so here it is the question I
have asked everybody how far is this
going to come down that's the question
so Patrick you and I better become
peacetime leaders pretty quick because
the war is on you get my drift
Robert yoke if we asked allowed the
audience to ask you a few questions
because they're there they're dying to
ask you questions wait I just want you
and I have a conversation no too
important you know when you said you
interviewed David Icke you're on the
list right now be careful okay my
attorney said the same thing that's that
my attorney they all said the same thing
right and when I came up with prophecy
this came out again and I wrote in 1999
came out in 2002 Wall Street came after
me because Wall Street is in cahoots
with the Federal Reserve Bank and that's
where I go back in time 1992 I wrote
fake fake money fake teachers fake
assets
mother book is you know who stole my
pension our pensions are stuffed with
toxic assets retirement is what they're
covering up
the old guys like me our host the baby
boomers our hos will never retire
you know the 401ks are gone you know
Australian superannuation is gone
Canada's RRSP is gone so Patrick we're
messing with some pretty interesting
people and so then I wrote this book
here years ago also it's called retire
young retire rich I wrote that for the
Millennials I said you guys better get
out of this mess pretty quickly you know
get out if you're counting on your 401k
or IRA or your superannuation or were
the guys people who are your whatever
your pension that was my book who stole
my pension just came out in 2020 so on
time I'm on schedule and delivering I
have what fuller called [ __ ] miserable
of the artifacts they can kill me now I
got my cash flow game out it's people
teaching people all over the world
screw the school system screw them okay
so that's what I am so Patrick you and I
you and me a brother
we better get peacetime pretty quick cuz
they're gonna take us out if not I think
I think you and I we need to go buy you
know a few thousand square miles of land
and we build our own small little
country and we start the civilization
and we sound like an Ram yeah shrugged
we we go and then we find this guy you
know John Galt yeah we build our own
society based our our own you know
beliefs economically and allow
innovation and creativity and very very
Loki Loki Loki you know build our own
country what do you think about that
Robert well that's what that's where the
vaccine comes in because the prediction
is that if you're not vaccinated you
can't drive a car you can't fly can't go
to restaurants is the ultimate control
it gonna be able to convince people to
do that you really think they're gonna
be able to force people to take a
vaccine I mean I heard what gets gates
at
the other day do you really think people
are gonna say yes I mean FDR back in
1933 when he made it illegal for us to
own gold there were still a lot of
people that held onto their gold and
they didn't give him back to the
government in confidence kid they kept
it for a long time do you really believe
they can get everybody to take the
vaccine well that's why London Rail was
taken down so Alex Jones was taken
that's he I agree with these guys Sarah
heads was taken down okay we're messing
with big people here you or not you have
a job you know every time I I see your
leadership you're more important alive
as a leader and I'm just saying in my
business model was to create artifacts
so people could teach people and get
away from that school system which is a
criminal operation when I say the
schools are a criminal operation you
know the question is where did where the
student loan debt can't come from
so today student loan debt if you look
at again you look at this crash here
student loan debt is bigger than
subprime debt so if you understand the
monetary system is that the only way
money can grow is to get people into
debt so when into thin September
September 2019 when the repo market the
shadow banking system which is a
commercial paper and corporate credit
and all that you know I mean Ford is now
junk Ford is now junk 8080 is now jump
one they've destroyed the stock market
they've been destroyed the corporation's
they keep the stock market afloat the
only ones left standing come out of
Silicon Valley now Google Apple YouTube
owned by gates so I'm treading on thin
ice right now so that's all I'm saying
Patrick you're too valuable alive and
there's too many people counting on you
to be the leader Rob
are you always this optimistic about you
know the future you know it's it's a
very very you know everything's going to
be alright
are you always this positive and
optimistic well the answer is you the
people who are like you know that said
Bobby Farren's and don't worry be happy
they're broke
what a great let me just say something
to all of you listening right now the
next the next thing that's gonna happen
is my book who stole my pension I
promise you the biggest news coming in
about six months is that old guys like
me are gonna say que pasa what happened
to my pension and they're gonna have to
work for the rest of their lives
they've become slaves you know in the
the word peasant I think I said that the
peasant comes from the word pay salt a
man of the land and all of these
employees are gonna be pays owns but
that's where mmt comes right here modern
monetary to you I call it Marxist money
there the theory or you bi University
basic income they're going to beg the
government to send them that check every
month and they just started that this
week it's happening we're now socialist
and we're now communist because the Fed
is going to take ownership of like
Boeing and all these things so its
central planning it's called central
bank central planning so we've gone
communist so are we like China
absolutely absolutely semi a pessimist
well I'm a pessimist and an optimist but
that's why I'm in such good shape today
was because going back to this year
think I started buying gold in 1972 when
it was illegal so I was a criminal my my
aircraft carrier sailed into Hong Kong
and while other guys were chasing women
and beer I was I said who can saw me
some gold and my education began in the
streets of Hong Kong and I bought a
Krugerrand from South Africa was about
fifty bucks
I still have that crew grin but isn't
some undisclosed foreign location that
they can't come and take it from me and
I do it legally you can move you can
hide goal legally and you can hang
called healing this the government knows
I have this goals I've done it legally
so they can't confiscate it that way but
it's not in this country so I've been a
pessimist about not I mean I just don't
trust our leaders I trust the mafia and
they're adding you a mafia but least the
Mafia they're more honest you know you
cross you break the rules they kill you
you know these bureaucrats running our
government you break the rules to give
you a promotion and a bonus laughs you
guys are more honest okay that's my I'm
a my a pessimist Patrick I have millions
in gold and silver
I sleep very well at night and every
time they know the Treasury does
announcing on print ten trillion the
feds gonna print ten trillion that's
twenty trillion they're going to destroy
the dollar so all of you guys out there
read Rich Dad Poor Dad lesson number one
the rich don't work for money because
our money is toxic our money is fake so
they well you know why do you have gold
and silver is because the more they
print this money which they will print
more I mean going back to my little
chart here this baby coming down right
now they're printing goal and the
printing dollars they're destroying
aren't they destroying Argentina that is
trying Brazil to destroying Africa that
is drawing Australia destroying Canada
destroying Mexico because the dollar is
a corrupt currency now I can get shot
for that but it's not like messing with
Bill Gates and I mean anyway
the point here is this wake up so I have
gold and silver and when they destroy
the dollar which they will in about ten
years I'll be better off so am i a
pessimist yes
am i optimist yes that's called being
I'm a realist that's the difference
and so all this Pollyanna people oh you
know I'm 50 years old now and I'm gonna
retire at 65 on what sweetheart
on what you know I was talking to my
personal trainer since I lost my job my
wife lost his job and I said yeah but
the economy will bounce back and I said
well what are you gonna do differently
oh let's just work harder that's an
optimist so what do you tell them what
do you tell them I can't tell him an
anything Patrick you know the worst
thing you can mess this with somebody's
beliefs if you know what I mean you know
like if you believe Jesus is God don't
question it if you believe Buddha is
Buddha
don't question Muhammad is God hey god
bless Muhammad you know I mean I don't
mess with the beliefs so if you believe
the US government is a good honest
people honest people in the Fed are
really here to protect the economy I
don't mess with you and if you believe
in job security I can't talk to you
because that's your belief belief is be
lie-bee-la
and so the what you and I are doing I
miss it again to all your listeners out
here you guys got to keep Patrick met
David alive and make him a peacetime
later don't go to war because that was
the same lesson my my company gave to me
it is it Robert don't go to war yeah
when I get threatened on Twitter and all
this other stuff I want to go to war you
know but I can't
our jobs are too important right now so
our job is to stay broadcasting pay up
and I don't know what gates homes but
I'm sure he can call anybody and say
shut down you know the World Health
Organization all this stuff I don't want
to go there it's not my that's not my
territory so first of all I if you want
to spend some time with some mafia
friends I've interviewed a few I can I
can make that introduction there's but
one of the bigger ones actually lives
where you live
only about fifty miles away from you I
don't know if you know who that one is
he's not from you who a guy named Sammy
the bull Gravano he's he's I saw that
interview yeah he's down the street from
you 15 miles from you Wow
he knows he knows the rules doesn't he
he he the rules are based on what you
said yeah yes so Robert so should I go
live with the David Eick interview or
should I not go live with the David I
can't if you just kind of hang on to it
I'm don't go live with it is that what
you're suggesting
yeah unrealistic yet no I have not I
recorded it and we're right not editing
it and we're gonna be debating whether
to go live with it or not but we haven't
yet we didn't do it live we recorded it
and then we're gonna release it so let
me give you back but you taught me my
friend are you wartime or peacetime what
do you think I know you want to go to
war right now and that and sometimes
it's better not to you're too important
alive that's the difference
Robert that's not too dramatic Robert
that's not being too dramatic I'm not
kidding you my father my father poor dad
and I ran for lieutenant governor of the
state of Hawaii and he took on he took
on the governor who was a ex-police
officer and so the ax the governor's
best friend ran the Hawaiian syndicate
and my father messed with him he never
worked again they took him out he's
alive but they basically took all of his
money away from him he died he died a
poor man he was I covered that my boy
who stole my pension that's how they got
my dad his pension
so that's why you know there's no
financial education in our schools so
you got you got to figure out Patrick
who's Superman and who's Superman cape
you want to step on and those are
decisions that leaders have to make
there there I think I told the story
last time I had to decide not to fight
and that's that's the difference so
wartime peacetime but also you know the
on the optimistic side I didn't know
this was coming
you know I thought it'd come in 2016 but
it came in 2020 I just think that I
didn't think that Grunch would be this
dastardly this desolate what he says
take people's livelihoods away and
quarantine us and violate the
Constitution of America and I'm walking
you know I live in a very rich
neighborhood and people won't talk to
you yeah I'm afraid of my own neighbors
now so what happened with Corona was not
not not the knot that we call it though
the virus it's fear they injected fear
into all of us that's the worst part
they're after we're done I'm afraid to
talk to people you know walking down my
sidewalk and people will actually go
across the street to avoid me you know I
mean that the fear and that's something
that you and I understand is that fear
can paralyze you but fear can also
inspire you you know fear stands for
false evidence appearing real
so when I feel fear I want to attack
other people want to run and if you
attack those that run will attack you
just here my prediction okay so I called
it it came in 2020 not 2016 the next
issue will be pensions and all of these
people who live in LA LA bill oh I'm now
65 who stole my pen shot
what's gonna happen to them
I have whole family members Patrick that
will be coming to me for their pension
on kin side and my sight
they don't have any money they're highly
educated people like my poor debt they
have nothing I know that community I
feel for I will tell you this because
the whole idea of the fact that the
wealthy is not going to be affected the
wealthy is gonna be fine you know that
and when I say the wealthy I'm talking
about the ultra high net worth 30
million plus type of wealthy I'm not
talking about 1 million 2 million I
think those guys can still take a hit
but I think the ultra high network guys
are gonna be fine
and I'll also think poor people are
gonna be fine let me explain what I mean
by the poor people I think those who are
not the workers who would be glad to get
unemployment checks I think they're
gonna be fine
my concern is middle America to continue
to grow that's my biggest concern and to
continue to grow middle America you know
you know 75% of them are three paychecks
away from being broke you know those
those are the guys that I'm concerned
and it's not like middle America doesn't
want to work it's not like middle
America is not willing to get up there
and do something sound like middle
America doesn't want to do something
about it do something about making their
50,000 a year 100,000 year 200,000 a
year I would even put $300,000 you as a
middle-income family I know statistic
says otherwise its 5% but to meet that
income range is who's got to be
protected and and the way you protect
them is by making sure the small
business owners protect it because 65
percent of jobs are created by the small
business owners and I will tell you the
part that we are similar is we're both
having elements of paranoia for me I was
born in Iran so I'm born paranoid I was
born when I came out of the room I was
questioning if my mom was my mom because
Middle Easterners are born that way we
could we question everything you know we
don't trust everything but on the other
side I also have a lot of optimism in
people's a bill
tee's ii think people's ability to
create people's ability to innovate and
people's ability to come together and
and eventually question things you know
I work I'm at the office right now just
so you know let me give you an idea what
my view looks like right I came to my
office my kid is over here because he's
gone crazy being at home so he's doing
his homework over here I'm at the office
and I got 20% of my employees that are
here everybody else is working from home
and people call me and they say Robert
is a Patrick why are you working why are
you at the office aren't you supposed to
be by yourself at a place you know away
from everyone I said look if the
president at the top can work if the
military can work if all these other
essential industries can work we're
working and then Governor Abbott the
governor of Texas said we uh
America needs Texas to go to work I
don't know if you saw that or not where
he gave a message the governor of Texas
saying America needs Texas to go to work
so for me I'm just a believer in knowing
that there's gonna be some people that
are gonna sit around saying you're not
gonna be able to push me around and
bully me I'm gonna go do my part and if
you push people too long like even the
most patient man my dad's one of the
most patient people I know he's so
patient it's ridiculous like he's in a
whole different level than me there's
only so many times my son or my daughter
his grandkids can pull on his jacket
until he finally says knock it off he
can be more patient than me maybe I need
six poles and he needs six feet but
eventually he says stop it I don't think
you can push people around for too long
I don't think you can do that for too
long and I think sometimes the most
powerful people in the world this is
this is my concern Robert then I'd be
curious to know what you say about this
here's my concern my concern is that
people eventually forget how powerful
they are people eventually are convinced
by the government or the powerful
politicians or whoever's at the top to
say oh we're special
we can make all the decisions for you
because we're smarter than you and then
the majority ends up believing that
nonsense that's my concern I'm talking
you know myself you knew you talked
about rich epic that when I read your
book in 1999 when I got out of the army
was the third book I read I told you
this multiple times life-changing book
I'm from a family that's a 1-point a GP
a family you know I was at one point a
GP a guy divorced family parents got a
divorce twice in 20 years born and
raised in Iran lived at a refugee camp
right after high school
army was the only option for me hey
you're a big muscular guy you left three
plates go to the army you'll do good so
I went into the army and then I got out
and then I was introduced to books okay
I was introduced to books once I was
introduced to books Robert then I
couldn't be controlled once I was once
that was introduced to books and I said
wait a minute you gotta be kidding me
you mean to tell me it's like this easy
to make a million bucks and you can be a
deca millionaire you can go out there
and do this and you can Wow so why did I
vote this way and why did I like this
politician and why did I like so maybe
my dad was right
in this area and my mom was right in
that area and they were wrong in those
other areas and now I get how all of
these other things are being used and
then I was free if that makes sense then
I was free I became a free thinker you
know what it is free thinker you know
free to choose so whether it was
capitalism and understanding Milton
Friedman's philosophies of what he was
doing I just won deep so my biggest
concern is that I hope people don't get
to a point where they're kind of like oh
that's it the the powers at the top tell
me what to do and I'm just gonna follow
orders because in a sense if you do
you're it's a different form of being in
jail today if you're sitting around it's
just the jail doesn't have a cell it
just happens to be your own house and I
I don't think they can go like this for
too long I just don't think they can go
like this for too long I think the
people are eventually as the mass is
gonna get sick of it and then they have
to listen to it so again I've been wrong
before I may be wrong again but I Bank
on I Bank on people cannot be bullied
and pushed around for too long until
they flip
almost the most the most patient man in
the world will flip if you push him for
too long I may be wrong Robert but
that's how I see this thing so let me
let me push you one more level beyond
that please you're still a young man and
like I said when I wrote this book fake
here and I wrote I wrote who stole my
pension
my father was six foot four was pretty
big for Japanese PhD but when he lost
his pension he became a wimp
look I won't let people know without
money people's spirits drain out of them
so I'll say it again as I got my best
education surfing every big wave surfer
knows that the biggest waves come in
threes so we just got number three it
came down in phrase two in March boom
boom
I'm predicting the what next way they
can control us is because there's no
pensions mark my words
CalPERS you know calloused in California
state pet just broke Illinois is broke
Kentucky is broke 401ks are toast these
hedge funds are toast so the question I
say to people you can be positive
thinking all you want but what's going
to happen when they make the money toxic
which in all we were to use it doesn't
buy anything anymore that's what
happened in Egypt with Arab Spring was
inflation went through the roof on him
and that's when they started to write
they couldn't eat you look at the
homelessness all across America that's
what happens so the future is actually
more of those homeless people
I see all over Hawaii in California and
Seattle and all this and so so without
money if it's not in your brain you
don't know how to create it and that's
all I'm saying to people the Fed
controls the money as well as the US
Treasury and at this moment as we speak
they're gonna pretend trillion more 10
trillion more and we don't know anything
about money
so you'd be like my poor dad great guy
positive thinker PhD but when they took
his [ __ ] pension away he turned into
a pile of jelly and that's what's going
to happen Patrick the next crisis is not
Corona crisis the next crisis his
pensions you mark my words on that
that's why the 401k was created in 1974
that's what Lew stole my pension is
about so when I talk to all these
positive thinking sons of a [ __ ]
they're the ones who are going to turn
on you when they don't have any money
that's all I'm saying you know that's
all I'd say so
oh you worry too much you know you don't
know what you're talking about and I
said well what's going to happen when
you're when you get ill cuz you know
illness most of the krona guys are old
guys we didn't take care of their health
that's the fact jack i wuold might take
care of my health I have the I of the
money to have concierge health care I
for the best so I should be target
market for coronavirus Kim Kim had it
she shook it that was a test she took
she's fine
I had it too it shook it but once a
person takes their money away like they
did my poor dad that's what I wrote
about and who stole my pension you out
money Patrick people can't function and
then they turn into primates animals
desperate they'll take they'll take
government mmt modern money I call it
Marxist monetary theory you bi Kang was
going to give everybody a thousand
dollars because we have no financial
education in our schools so we're gonna
be positive McCann all that but I tell
you what right now I have brothers and
sisters in their seventies I know who is
going to be in their pension it's me so
I was a dumbshit surfer it comes in
waves of threes it happened in 2022 peak
with three waves down already it's never
fallen so fast Patrick they're printing
money to stop the Hindenburg from going
into the ground they're bailing out the
you know it I know it but now they have
to come up with mm tea to keep the poor
and the middle class from rioting and
killing each other this is not an
accident is what I'm saying
the coronavirus was just the red Black
Swan that talent I mean nothing talent
talks about and what is revealing is
exactly as Buffett said who's swimming
naked you and I know those hedge funds
are broke right now my best friend just
sold his his best 1.8 billion to a hedge
fund he says I [ __ ] them all because
they don't know about real estate their
hedge fund guys so now they're had their
their properties are crashing commercial
real estate is crashing dip is gonna
pile to the ceiling that's the shadow
banking system and when I talk to even
my my highly educated friends they don't
know what the repo market is they don't
know what commercial paper is they don't
know that Ford went from triple B to
junk they don't know they say Oh what's
the stock market doing today they don't
know Patrick
so that's why I created the cash flow
board game I won't Rich Dad Poor Dad and
all this so people have got to start
teaching people positive thinking is
stupidity if you're broke you've got to
have something between this air on that
ear you gotta know assets from
liabilities you can see the balance
sheets that's all I'm saying I've been
saying it for 20-something years now so
here question for you if you're saying
you don't know what to say if you're
saying there's no solutions if you're
saying pensions are going out which by
the way I'm in the industry ie that's a
that we've known that for a while with
pensions and Social Security Robert why
should anybody buy your books why should
anybody your books right now if there's
no if you if you're thinking doom and
gloom if that's around the corner
because Patrick you you know the answer
100 people for look at the message you
see every day in your work I see them
every day in my work I see all the
positive thinking guys oh I just state
don't worry be happy you know gonna go
to Margaritaville look at the
Millennials they're the biggest in depth
generation in history look at what we've
done to our kids how much financial
education do our schools put out zero is
that an accident that's all I'm asking
people to think but all these guys who
are positive are I don't have to worry
you know i my personal trainer
they're unemployed he says yeah but
we're very successful people said but
you know nothing about money so some
people will get educated ninety ninety
six percent won't that's the odds so
there's no or people to there's still an
out for people to throughout these times
you know capitalize and create wealth
and take care of their own this
difference between money and long-term
wealth look I don't know if you know
this but I don't have a financial
planner I have a private office I have a
team of advisers of accountants
attorneys bookkeepers and all this I run
as a business you know this qivana
crisis whatever it is it's making me a
very rich man
I have millions of dollars of gold and
silver I'm completely out of the stock
market I don't need a pension that was
my plan it wasn't a mistake lesson
number one and Rich Dad Poor Dad the
rich don't work for money and the
average person see I read Rich Dad Poor
Dad I got a lot out of us had you got
less than one and the reason lesson one
is important is because right here's
1971 Nixon took the dollar off the gold
standard and it became fake and so
people are so desperate today cash you
know money whatever they call it today
is like intravenous it's the drug money
is a drug they just stick it in my veins
baby stick in my veins I can feel good
for today let me pay my bills me pay my
mortgage that's what they agitate
Patrick
you know that I know that you take that
you take that money away with what has
happened all over the world like in
Argentina Zimbabwe Venezuela they're
gonna riot you know that I know that hmm
I love Australia the Aussie dollar
dropped from eighty to fifty five cents
I said that the average man average
person or sauce trillium that's how
stupid Americans are that's how stupid
they are highly educated stupid people
like my rich dad
my poor debt so that's why I do what I
do so the question I ask you the people
who are watching ears get out before
that or it's called wipeouts and
millions right now Patrick you know it
and I knew it my being wiped out as we
speak as we speak as Buffett said people
are swimming naked they're going to turn
in the keys to the Lexus their condos
the second house my friends were in
commercial real estate they're hurting
that they were rich but their tenants
are moving out retail restaurants and I
don't think that was a mistake
I think the corona virus is a cover-up
for the September 2019 crash of the repo
market is in who stole my pension and
the average person talking I'm talking
to you right now they don't know what
the repo market is they don't know the
shadow banking system they don't know a
commercial paper they don't know any of
that that's the problem and that's what
I've been saying you know like I said I
was cruising along here I saw this wave
building says a surfing okay something's
coming something's coming no that's no
longer a short break this one's big
and that's when right here I wrote a
cash-flow board game Rich Dad Poor Dad
and prophecy I said this is coming so
you go to a Rich Dad dot-com you can see
me on CNN in January 2008 I'm telling
wolfbloods
Leeman is going down and he got upset
because it got out it's not supposed to
get out just like the coronavirus on a
Wuhan was not supposed to get out
supposedly but once it got out then they
never invited me back so go to Rich Dad
dot-com and look up CNN Wolf Blitzer I'm
calling it six seven eight months early
if people had got out they would have
lost everything I got out way back here
in Vietnam I saw the light in Vietnam I
said why am i killing people here why am
i killing them why what did I ever do to
me and you being from around this yep I
you know what I'm talking about
because your country it's the hot spot
right now you know because you stood up
to America and that's saying it's right
or wrong I agree or disagree but you
know you don't stand up to America cuz
they'll send the drones in you know
[ __ ] drone pilots of cowards now you
fire that drone missile you hit one
target but you kill 20 people alongside
and you're never in danger you know
drone pilot just sits back in Langley
Virginia and fires us rocket or drops of
whatever they do today and they killed
people with no rest to themselves when I
was killing people I had to kill him up
front they could kill me too I had to go
onto the ground and pick up my guys who
were wounded
but now America just kills them from the
air indiscriminately that's why I do and
I say what I do it's my friend peace
time war time
I asked you that question and that all
the people listening you're the people
that are counting you on you to stay
alive you've got to get smarter and go
peacetime there's enough fights out
there we don't have to choose pick right
you know they're all saying pick our
women and our battles wisely you know
you don't wanna fight to nuts
so be careful your trip we're treading
on Superman's cape right now that was
David Icke so Minnie Mouse is better to
be Minnie Mouse today than Superman gets
smarter look I have all of these
artifacts this is an artifact it's in 50
languages they take me out it's still
out there my board game it's an artifact
it's they can take me out it's still out
there
joining me is what I learned from
Buckminster Fuller I don't have
financial planners because they work for
Wall Street nothing wrong with them but
I don't need them I don't need Wall
Street to make money
I am millions on gold and silver stored
outside the country you know why as if I
have to run I'm running I'll leave it
all behind
Robert some may say you're scared what
do you have to say to that some may say
it's Roberts scared right now yeah I
don't want to be stupid so you'd rather
us just say something you know I went to
Vietnam twice if I was scared I wouldn't
have gone like these [ __ ] who stayed
behind it spit on me when I came back
who a geek who became school teachers
professors
lawyers you know I went to court in New
York and the judge said I don't like you
and I don't like Donald Trump those are
the people that are afraid
I lost the case because she didn't like
Donald Trump she didn't like me she
ruled against me just on that principle
that's the left as you know and I don't
take sides right I left last night but
let me tell you something if you've ever
served the biggest wave I ever surpass
16 feet the reason I served the 16
footer because that was it there was one
coming behind of it I still remember
that day I was a cut school on high
school student I went out and I was
going holy mackelson I'm trying for the
smaller waves and I go out and ago and
somebody yells outside outside means
there's this wave coming so I decide to
take the smaller one at 16 feet I never
went out again you know why because fear
taught me something important you're not
good enough yet you haven't practiced
enough yet to write this is a different
ride my best friend not my best friend
but one of my closest friends Karl
Rahner he died next year at Sunset Beach
big wave surfing is not for [ __ ] what
you and I are doing is not for [ __ ]
that's the difference we we manifest our
fear and we focus it in different ways
the real cowards the ones that walk
around me on the street and look at milk
I don't have a mask on that's the coward
it's the coward is going to say well
where's my check from the government or
where's my retirement
that's the coward fear is false evidence
it's what do you do with it so I think
we should finish on that the first time
we did it on your life it went ballistic
for a second time we're doing it on mine
it's going nuts I think we have enough
it's what hit you I'm sure that one's
gonna be nuts and you stay alive my
friend you stay alive yes yes so by the
way Robert for everybody else that's
watching a lot of you guys are saying
save this live I'm gonna save this live
on valuet in a short clip
Robert I'll send it to you if you could
share it on your instant I'll share this
awesome find it and we'll do this again
in the next few days Robert you're a
great storyteller you're great to listen
to and very insightful and you just keep
same message you stick to it so
eloquently and your ability to give
metaphors and stories from the past is
that a whole different your black built
eight degree when it comes down to that
so I appreciate your time buddy really I
really enjoyed it the more more we're
doing this it's getting even better for
the audience I'm looking forward to our
next one thank you one last word I was
the most important the best feeling in
the world was a rise strapped in with my
co-pilot that's when you know a band of
brothers and you elect my brother about
there so you stay alive much love man
much luck thank you take care
buh-bye buh-bye I